hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about triggering
your fat burning hormone now in some of
the other videos I talked about growth
hormone and some of the other fat
burners because there's six of them but
rarely have ever talked about the
hormone called glucagon now what is
glucagon it's not glucose it glucagon is
a hormone that triggers fat burning it
may is made by the pancreas and it does
the opposite of insulin okay so insulin
is the main fat making hormone glucagon
is one of the main fat burning hormones
okay so there's a couple things that
will trigger glucagon number one
exhaustive exercise now here's the key
this word exacts exhaustive okay regular
exercise that's not exhausting like
bicep curls is that's about it that's
not going to do anything so here's the
key with with stimulating glucagon you
want to do a exercise it involves all of
your muscles to an intense degree
whether that is a bootcamp class
maybe it's burpees which is a type of
exercise where you're jumping down and
coming up maybe it's doing the jump rope
maybe it's a spin class
maybe it's an aerobic class kickboxing
p90x all that is awesome but it's very
easy to over train a lot of people can't
handle that the optimum if you're doing
exhaustive exercise the optimum time is
between 20 minutes and 30 minutes why
because if you do too much it's going to
take you a long time to recover like
some people that do an hour okay you
want to do an hour that's fine but just
do that once a week don't do it every
day or every other day because you
probably can't recover now if you're in
really good shape you probably can but
typically the people that I see they
don't recover that easily so I would do
20 minutes of this every other day but
the key is the exhaustive like you
should be done and sweating your butt
off and like oh my gosh that was an
incredible
okay I like to chop wood I like to take
the wood that I chopped and lift it and
carry it I take logs and I carry them
that's a really good work for work out
for me especially in the winter when I
can't run my bike right so the point is
that glucagon is triggered by exhaustive
extra exhaustive exercise and protein
now in some other videos I talk about
protein also can trigger insulin so we
have this fat burning and without making
hormone doing the opposing things but
the point is you're not going to gain
weight if you consume a moderate or a
small amount of protein okay it's not
going to happen because you have this
effect it's when you do a lot of protein
that you will actually you could gain
some weight because that's overdoing it
but you don't worry about that so
protein is important in stimulating
glucagon alright now the last thing that
triggers glucagon is decreasing insulin
because it works an opposite to insulin
so how are you going to keep insulin low
well I have a ton of videos on that it's
basically you cut out the sugars you cut
out the snacking cut out the hidden
sugars and excessive protein and you'll
start to increase glucagon so those are
some really important points so just to
summarize if you could take an exercise
and workout intensely and you can also
add some of the other data in other
videos where I'm talking about sleeping
so we spiked the pulse rate after you
get your energy get a good sleep at
night or maybe even take a nap does even
it's not even necessary that it's a full
eight hours you can break it up but the
point is that we want to get enough
quality sleep to handle this exercise to
recover you to the point where we really
see some serious weight loss and
triggering of this hormone so I just
want to bring this point up it's not
just any exercise that's exhaustive
exercise okay all right I'll see you in
the next video